welcome back let's get straight stuck
into the press preview then it's our
first look at the front pages and
tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with uh annabelle denham and
rachel shabby we'll speak to them in a
moment after we've had a look at some of
those front pages for you sunday's
papers beginning with the observer
leading with a warning to liz trust not
to pack her cabinet with johnson
loyalists as senior tories fear a deeply
divided party if she becomes prime
minister
the express shares a statement from
boris johnson telling conservative mps
to stop their infighting and to unite
behind their new leader
while the sunday telegraph talks about
the latest pledges from front-runner
mistrust she says she's done with
sticking plasters over problems when it
comes to tackling britain's energy
crisis
and the mirror also covers the tory
leadership race but with this headline
tory mp's plot to bring back boris
sunday times leads with remarks from
ukraine's president zielenski on the
energy crisis with the leader stressing
that financial hardships in the west are
a price worth paying to avert world war
the sun reveals a new documentary
featuring emily attack the actress opens
up about her experiences of attracting
unwanted harassment from a young age
and the star has this story mi5 looking
for new agents with the headline for
your pies only as it says the secret
services are looking for larger new
recruits
and don't forget by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen join the program
you can check out the front pages of
twice papers while you watch us
discussing them and tonight we are
joined by rachel shabby
the director of communications at the
institute of economic affairs annabelle
denham good to see you both uh lots to
talk about um and why don't we start
with
the sunday telegraph annabelle um
feels like forever this leadership race
doesn't it but it is uh over in the
sense that we will find out on monday
who the new prime minister is going to
be around about noon they start work on
tuesday
and uh what a job it is going to be liz
trust has kept her cards fairly close to
her chest hasn't she on how she's going
to solve
or try and tackle the cost of living
crisis but the sunday telegraph has a
little bit more detail
yes i think one of the main criticisms
of liz trust during this contest has
been that she's been lacking in detail
when it comes to how
her government would deal with the cost
of living in crisis and i expect that
we're going to see her puts finally put
some flesh on the bones in the coming
days like you say jonathan a torturously
long process to elect the new leader of
the conservative party but finally it is
drawing to a close it will be over by
about 12 30 uh on monday and here we
have specifically liz truss's plan to
bring down energy prices um and really
help us tackle the cost of living crisis
um with both short-term support which of
course is essential the next government
must find ways to
cushion the impact of soaring energy
prices for the most vulnerable
households but also this long-term
overhaul of the markets and again aids
are insisting that her plans for reform
are yet to be finalized but certainly to
me at least this
is welcome rhetoric um the government
has tinkered with the energy markets
incessantly over the last couple of
decades and that's how we've ended up
with these sticking plasters we've had
endless subsidies and conferences and
targets and what we really need is a
route and branch reform of the market
which at the moment scarcely resembles a
market at all so
not very much a game really in the way
of detail one presumes um that she will
put a stop to us shipping for frac
shipping gas at high cost um from
overseas while adopting that leave it in
the ground mentality here um by ending
the moratorium on fracking potentially
um that to me would be very welcome news
you know the shell gas revolution in the
u.s um has led to energy prices there
being around 40 percent lower than ours
um we'll see what she does on when full
taxes though uh she's said to be uh in
opposition to them um so here's this
trust really trying to set up a solution
to the cost of living crisis
specifically those energy prices um
because the conservatives have been
paying for it with with lower support we
saw that bounce for kierstama and labour
after they announced uh that they would
support freezing prices so perhaps we'll
see her answer to that yeah rachel what
do you make of this you know she's
saying no more sticking plants at
plasters but of course her party has
been in power for more than a decade and
they have had a chance to to to try and
tackle this
yeah you're absolutely right and this is
the slate of hand that conservatives
want to you know
pull
on on the nation of
we didn't do it even though the
conservatives obviously have you said
have been in power for the last 12 years
and of course this terrible damage look
i welcome someone you know the person
most likely to be um prime minister on
monday saying right no more sticky
plasters but the question is what's she
going to do and this is mostly rhetoric
the rhetoric is suggesting
exactly as annabelle says a two-pronged
attack um cushion the impact for people
but also
um
stop uh uk dependency on oil and gas
imports but the question is how will you
achieve both those things interestingly
there's a quote here from uh one of liz
truss's key economic advisers gerard
lyons
who is saying look um government is
going to have to cap energy prices
you're going to have to intervene
um
when they're spiraling to this
absolutely ludicrous
excess then the government needs to cap
those prices so that does suggest that
the policy that kiyostama announced a
few weeks ago might get adopted by the
government but obviously obviously we're
looking at a market that has failed if
the energy prices are uh spiking to the
extent
that people are you know on the verge of
destitution are feeling suicidal
absolutely besides themselves with
desperate worry
um you know it's a snapshot of britain
would show you the extent of despair
over that clearly those energy companies
who by the way are price gouging and
paying themselves and their
shareholders very well thank you very
much clearly that is failure that is a
market that has failed and the solution
to that obviously is to take them into
public ownership and the reason i say
obvious is because in polls even
conservative voters say that that should
happen so that's the sort of root and
branch we're going to talk in those
terms that's the sort of thing that's
needed um i suspect
unfortunately that's not the line that
liz trust is going to go down i just
want to say a quick word about
oil and gas and fracking fracking apart
from the huge environmental damage is
hugely ineffective renewables are far
cheaper and come online far quicker i
would also point you to the huge
donations that the conservatives have
received in the last few years from oil
and gas companies um and invite you to
join the dots all right
loads covered there well done rachel
excellent
uh well let's let's move
let's move on to the front of the
observer because if it is liz trust who
goes into number 10 on tuesday then
there's a warning here uh pack the
cabinet with johnson loyalists at your
peril and it leads us annabelle also on
to the front of the sunday express
because boris johnson has been writing
for them and he says stop fighting and
back the new prime minister how easy
annabelle will it be for the new prime
minister to unite the tories if she does
pack the cabinet with boris johnson
loyalists
well i think she's certainly got a
challenge on her hands but possibly you
know unifying the conservative party is
less of a challenge than the economic
headwinds um and and the forthcoming
winter of discontent no so you're right
boris johnson on the in writing for the
express is calling for unity of course
we've had a summer of essentially blue
on blue attacks which have brought
pretty untold damage on the conservative
party there's a concern now that when
the next general election takes place
most likely at the moment in 2024 that
it it might be for the conservatives to
lose that they're going to really
struggle to
round up public support um after not
just the last couple of months this
internal leadership contest but of
course everything that has gone before
not to mention the fact that they've
been in power for 12 years and people
may be wanting change perhaps some
fastest after the coronavirus pandemic
um so certainly there are huge
challenges there and i'll let you say
the observer cover really story has two
strands you know the first is is that if
liz trust doesn't um appoint some rishi
sunak supporters to her cabinet that
that she's going to really struggle to
uh bring about the kind of unity that
could enable the conservatives to win uh
in
2024 and the second strand is you know
the concern that uh trust allies such as
ian duncan smith and nadine doris um
if appointed to top positions might try
to use their influence to scrap the
parliamentary inquiry into whether doris
johnson deliberately misled parliament
over partygate that's the privileges
committee investigation that's uh that's
still ongoing um but to the first strand
you know i i think it it it will be an
immense challenge for liz trust there's
a
detail in the sunday telegraph uh
tomorrow about who the most uh likely uh
team in the cabinet will be and that
certainly indicates that uh you know she
is going to try and bring in some former
rivals uh mps from issue soon acts camp
and the left of the party in an effort
to unite parliament we're just running
we're running out of time i want to get
rachel's views on this and also have
views on the front of the mirror tory
mp's plot to bring back boris how much
of a problem uh rachel is it um for the
next prime minister that polls suggest
boris johnson is still more popular
amongst members than either sunak or
trust
yeah it's not great is it but i think
that points as well to the unpopularity
of liz trust and i think the guardian is
tracking some polling that shows that
the more
the more conservative voters are ex
never mind the general public are
exposed to this trust the less they like
her so polling has tanked over the last
few weeks of this um you know groundhog
day
leadership campaign
so that's a bit of a worry for trust but
i do think you know she does seem to be
doing exactly what the tory backbenchers
are warning her against doing which is
to pack the cabinet with
uh johnson allies potentially um and
that that is one to watch in terms of
this rehabilitation
of boris johnson that many of his allies
who will be influential figures in
cabinet potentially uh seem seem hell
bent on pursuing yeah yeah and of course
whoever takes over a big mountain to
climb with labour uh even further ahead
in the polls okay thank you both for the
moment uh still to come police fear a
hard winter of surging crime and several
because of the cost of living in crisis
discussing that and more at front pages
in a moment
[Music]
welcome back annabelle and rachel still
with us uh front page of the sunday
times rachel um and there's a real real
concern uh about potential civil unrest
if people uh can't keep warm and can't
feed themselves
well yeah that's right and i think this
just points to the the sense of
you know potential social breakdown that
we're looking at because of this
horrendous um cost of living emergency
essentially that the uk is facing so
this is a leaked report um from uh that
was drawn up by police chiefs over the
summer and it shows you to think that
the extent to which they themselves are
worrying about social unrest they're
talking about um civil disobedience but
also an upsurge in
the kind of crime that you see an
upsurge in when there is financial
hardship of this scale so theft
shoplifting burglary but also the sort
of crime that has an exploitation
element like um
prostitution or
recruiting teenagers to county line
gangs so that's obviously incredibly
worrying
it's worrying that the police chiefs are
worried but it's also not entirely
surprising because that is the scale
of absolute anguish that people are in
and
you know that it's like this breakdown
of a social contract between the
government and the public where
you know you have a regular job and that
allows you to pay living expenses um
accommodation but also food be able to
put food on the table and be able to pay
your bills and the fact that people
actually in employment
uh never mind more vulnerable people in
society
cannot do that anymore it's such a
fundamental breakdown of that contract
that we have
um that you can see you know something
has to give and if there's no other
outlet you can see how that would
explode into the sort of unrest that
police chiefs are worried about which is
exactly why we need we need an
announcement and a big announcement very
soon isn't it um also on the front of
the sunday times and it leads on uh from
what rachel was saying annabelle is that
uh president zielenski has said that the
energy crisis is a price that we have to
pay in order to avoid world war the pain
is worth it uh he suggests but if we do
see social breakdown and unrest and
support for ukraine in the country will
surely waver won't it
i think it's going to be an immensely
difficult time it's not surprising that
president salenski is really imploring
the west not to lose resolve we had the
first lady of ukraine today reminding us
that the uk counts pennies whereas the
ukrainians count casualties um what
worries me is there hasn't really been
any mention of peace talks you know how
long is this war going to go on and how
long will the west be able to maintain
its solidarity when we are feeling the
effects of the war increasingly acutely
inflation is rising um in europe the
euro has fallen to its lower lowest
level against the dollar for uh two
decades i think that kiev and zielenski
is really aware of of the risk of global
fatigue public life while public
lighting is is dimmed and we're being
told to take uh cold showers to really
ration the amount of energy that we're
using and of course uh today we've had
uh the ongoing maintenance issues should
we call them with nordstrom one that's
going to further choke uh supplies of
gas coming to the continent which is
going to lead to bills skyrocketing
further so as we feel the the pinch as
we feel the effects of the war in
ukraine it it's going to be interesting
to see and perhaps very worrying really
to see
just how much support we're able to
muster and continue to muster for the
war in ukraine
okay um we were going to discuss serena
williams on the front of the observer
but perhaps we'll do that in the next
hour
great picture of her after losing at the
us open uh we'll talk about her legacy
in the next down thank you both very
much indeed come